it's finally happened Red Dead
Redemption too is now out on PC if you
want to know our opinions on the game
you can still go check out our full
review from last year that hasn't
changed but I got Michael hi I'm here
who has had a chance to check out the PC
version and that is what we're going to
talk about today is how the PC version
stacks up Michael what do you think the
PC version you know if you can get it to
run it's a it's a great version of the
game there are several things that may
attract you to the PC version the first
thing I want to talk about is graphics
options now that whenever there's a
proper PC port of any big console game
or game that was exclusive on two
consoles graphics options are always a
big deal like GTA 5 Red Dead Redemption
2 has so many options in the menu you
don't worry about all of them but if you
if you're into tinkering your your
settings of course there's native 4k
support there's 1440p even ultra wide
support I play in 21 by 9 and it's nice
to play a Red Dead Redemption 2 with the
vastness of the open world in ultra
widescreen and it looks great in that
regard this course you can change all
the quality settings as well texture
shadows lighting all that good stuff
draw the distances have been improved
and there's also things like
tessellation global illumination so the
whole roster of graphics options are
there and if you look at the PC
requirements and recommended specs
they're not too high but if you want to
have all these bells and whistles I
would recommend that you have a very
high-end PC I'm working with an Intel
Core i7 7700 K and an NVIDIA RTX 2080
and I'm playing in 1080p ultra wide
there's a little bit more than standard
1080p in terms of pixel density and I
have everything cranked up to either
Ultra or high and I'm getting decent
frame rates about 60 to 80 okay
anything beyond that and like if you try
and do native 4k on PC you're gonna need
maybe a 20 atti and of course you want
to bump up though some of those quality
settings as well so it is if you want
all that stuff you're gonna need to have
a fairly high end PC yeah I actually did
a couple of tests with one of our office
pcs which has a 20 80 TI and I also
tried to max out everything I turned
everything as high as I could
we turn it and I was getting yeah like
Max 80 minimum was like 40 and you could
definitely see it fluctuating at points
as I was playing but it is who a boy is
it a demanding game if you want to try
and turn on everything speaking of the
game being demanding I think one of the
most important aspects of this being a
PC version is framerate mmm-hmm now the
console versions were locked at about 30
frames per second which is fine it works
well for this style of game because this
is not a competitive FPS where a
framerate is going to be an inherent
advantage but it is nice to play this
game at a smooth 60 or higher framerate
I have a 144 Hertz monitor and boy
things look a lot smoother so I think
that's an aspect that a lot of PC gamers
are gonna want to get out of this now
the PC version looks incredible so does
the Xbox one X and ps4 Pro version so I
would say the PC version if you have
that high-end PC it's going to it can
look better than those console versions
but they all are visually stunning
regardless so here the leg up is having
that that added framerate and you know
it helps in combat we were talking about
how maybe it's a little bit easier to
aim now that you have a smoother frame
rate you're not fighting the game itself
in terms of trying to get headshots or
moving around the environment a little
bit more especially when the action gets
hot and there's a lot going on it's a
little bit easier to just kind of take
in the moment when you're in the middle
of a huge firefight when you have higher
frame rates so that that's a that's a
cool advantage to have that's inherent
to a PC version there are some visual
bugs though I noticed that trees
sometimes just get like glitchy and
start fizzing out in the like out in the
environment didn't happen that often it
wasn't game breaking or anything but it
was kind of noticeable when I'm was
chilling in the camp and I just see
trees freaking out and stuff yeah I
think it's cuz it looks so good most of
the time that is small stuff like that
that really isn't a big deal
right it's a little more noticeable
right a game like this I don't know if
this is specific to the PC version but I
did notice that when I go into first
person view and I'm talking to some of
the NPC's sometimes their mouths don't
move when they're saying something yeah
a little weird but again that is it is a
rare occasion and what it does happen
it's noticeable but other than that it's
there isn't much in terms of visual
books one thing I did notice that I'm
not sure how prevalent it is but I
noticed that there were some animations
that were actually a little lower frame
rate like I think of the strap on on
Arthur's gun was actually like the
animation on it seemed a little bit
aware then 60 frames a second which is
something that you never noticed on
console that's a little bit noticeable
on PC when you're running at higher
frames for the most part though like
that I just noticed it with that one
example I don't know how prevalent that
is but that's a minor thing that's worth
anything
one thing to note about the graphics
options though is that there are
multiple options for anti-aliasing which
is an important setting to use note that
msaa
is the most demanding so if you're gonna
crank that to either four times or eight
times to get the full effect you're
gonna take a big cut in frame rate so
what I've been doing is using temporal
anti-aliasing and then cracking up the
temporal sharpness to kind of get rid of
that softer look that it may give if you
don't crank up the schrödinger's now the
reason why the PC version and all its
graphics options are important is
because a lot of Red Dead Redemption too
has to do with your relationship to the
world when you're horseback riding to
from one town to another you're soaking
in the fastest of the open-world is how
how pretty it looks how the sunset looks
how the Sun blasts through the trees
when you're hunting and stuff like that
and a lot of it has to do with the
cinematic quality of its cutscenes and I
think that when you're playing on a ps4
pro or xbox 1 x version those qualities
shine through and it does is well on PC
so there's no huge advantage in terms of
you know is this a different experience
on PC when it comes to visuals like well
if you played on the upgraded consoles
other than framerate I think that you're
getting mostly the same type of
experience well then one of the things
that is potentially different on PC is
mounted keyboard support how did that
feel
keyboard mouse controls are important to
me even for games that aren't
competitive fps and I think they've
translated well to read that to some of
the menu stuff is weird because when you
pull up a menu and you want to look that
look at a diff
items my instinct is to hover over the
items with the mouse cursor to kind of
highlight it and see like it's details
and stuff the problem is that the game
doesn't recognize you hovering over them
as you know switching to I want to look
at what this item is
and instead you would have to use the
arrow keys to kind of shuffle through
your menu and but not WASD so that's
kind of your only option by default and
I think that that's a little weird
because I would rather have it if I
hover my mouse over it's like okay you
can highlight a different item and so
what I would do is click it and like
that would be to use it so that kind of
threw me off a little bit but these are
minor things in the grand scheme and you
know just being able to navigate
navigate the environment and use your
mouse for aiming is a really cool
feature to have of course and with the
Red Dead - there's so many different
systems and mechanics at play now you're
pulling out your satchel you go into
your horse looking into your inventory
they're picking up things looting stuff
and there's just so many different
controls that it's nice to have that on
a keyboard instead of maybe fumbling
through the controller for the first
couple of hours now when it comes to
controller support though that control
scheme has translated one-for-one from
the consoles so if you rather play with
the controller that control scheme is
fine just takes some getting used to and
you just plug in a dual shock for or an
Xbox one controller or even an Xbox 360
controller and you're good to go
straight off the bat well I think one
thing that's worth addressing even
though it might be resolved by the time
this video is out is the launch day
crashes that the game was having seemed
like it was having a bit of a rough
launch did you have any of that in your
experience I did I would crash to the
desktop when I would try to load the
story missions and I had one where it
was in the loading screen and it said it
exited the game exited unexpectedly then
another one where I was at least a
minute into the intro cutscene and then
it would crash there there were some
workarounds that I was able to figure
out such as using making sure that was
using DirectX 12 which is a menu option
also updating your drivers your video
drivers
I'm using AMD or Nvidia and make sure
that you're using the most up-to-date
drivers of course and a combination of
those things got me to run the game
smoothly later on on on launch day there
was a patch that rolled out and it seems
to have fixed most things for most
players
by all accounts so aside from a fairly
rough launch day I think that's you know
this game is up and running quite well
if you have the proper PC roxor did add
some content to the PC version mostly
side stuff that is largely
inconsequential to the main story but
they are there they have extra bounty
missions gang hideouts treasure maps as
a new stranger if you're looking out for
that some trinkets some weapons horses
but this is all complimentary stuff that
you know it's it's not going to affect
the overall experience and but those
those things are there there's also a
photo mode so if you like taking
pictures gonna get Arthur looking all
nice and stuff and or as dirty as you
want really because decimal can get real
dirty and take some nice photos you have
some options like contrast filters
changing camera angles themselves
because they have a couple that make it
look like the photos and the loading
screen and stuff yeah and you know Red
Dead Redemption who has such wonderfully
detailed environments that in that game
is prime for a photo mode that about
covers everything I want to talk about
in terms of the Red Dead Redemption to
PC version so if you haven't played this
game it's it's an absolutely wonderful
game we gave it our game to be here for
2018 so has our stamp of approval and
yeah if you have if you want to play
this on PC if you've been holding out
this is definitely you know a version
that you can play that's Oren's properly
at least now it does alright well thank
you very much Michael and for any other
Red Dead related coverage or just any
coverage about any video game really
stay tuned to game spot
[Music]
you
[Music]